they'll feel okay about you know
prostituting themselves because these
are they call them PCS private
collectors when you're liking porn and
stuff and basically all that is is a guy
who's got the money to pay adult film
stars you know like a super high
escorting fee but then they
the whole thing is you're supposed to be
going for a photo shoot or a video right
to film a video but that come on that's
not really like half the time they don't
even film
all right Genevieve uh where did you
grow up where are you from originally oh
um from Denver Colorado
uh I was adopted when I was real little
like under a year old so my parents were
white
and you're adopted parents yeah how
would you how was your family
[ __ ] up really [ __ ] up
extremely [ __ ] up in my ways
um my parents are really not good people
like really bad people the kind of
people you know you read stories about
and like
the kind of people who I think breed
rapists murderers like they're just
really sick people they're super
religious they were
really abusive like really really
abusive
in both ways
um well my dad like basically started
torturing me at a certain point you know
like um
okay well so the whole dynamic of our
family changed after
um it was I was being sexually abused by
one of my older brothers and so when
that came out
everything just everything changed you
know like I because I don't ever
remember our family being that bad but
then after that it was like there was
nothing good you know
and my parents um they basically I was
like sort of the enemy at that point you
know even though I was very very young
and uh
just everything started to fall on me
like you know all their frustrations
um just I was like kind of singled out
because really the like the physical
abuse was not happening to my other
brothers and sisters
just me
so
you know it was and we're talking like
pretty extreme physical abuse you know
like my dad was the first guy to ever
closed fist hit me in the face you know
and when I was I don't know like
probably like 10 years old or something
do you know your biological parents no
no chance no even of whatever with that
but I don't even like actually I really
don't kind of like when people ask me
like oh your real mom and dad or
whatever because like I was adopted by
the time I was like six months old and
so my parents are my parents they're you
know I really don't like that
terminology that gets used because
I think it
lessons like you know what the fact that
they were you know that was all I've
ever known as my parents
I don't believe that whole blood is
thicker than water stuff you know
what kind of kid were you in high school
what what kind of kid were you in high
school oh well um well when I was in
high school which wasn't for very long I
was bad I was I was pretty um outrageous
I guess you could say
I was um I was not popular and I was
I mean maybe I was pretty but I didn't
know that and so like I was um
oh plus I was Asian and like there was
not hardly ever any Asians ever where I
was going to school or growing up or
anything so
like uh kids would make fun of me or
just I was different you know like Asian
chicks were not quite in yet then a
couple years later it took off but uh so
I don't know high school was horrible
for me actually all all the schools were
horrible elementary middle school and I
didn't stay in high school very long at
all did you graduate no
no I got my GED like whatever but I I
actually skipped a lot of grades like a
lot and so I was in high school when I
was like 11 years old
that's early yeah I I went from like I
did kindergarten through fourth then I
skipped to sixth grade so I went from
elementary skipped fifth went to middle
school did sixth grade only skipped
seventh and eighth and went right to
high school
why did you skip stuff from the names uh
because I was
because I'm an intelligent person
because I have a you know high IQ or
whatever
but
just because I'm really intelligent does
not mean I cannot be a dumb [ __ ]
because I am a pretty dumb [ __ ] at
times so hard to get into sex work
um ah
Okay this may sound weird
I think before I even knew what sex work
was or anything I I think I knew that I
was like sort of destined for that I
don't know how to explain that but like
though well the first time I did a date
or whatever I was not even 18 I was um
I think 16 or something and I had met
this guy in a hotel in downtown Denver
and he was filming like a promo for a
like UFC fight so like I thought he was
famous
and so then um he just started talking
to me and then he took me back to his
room and I had no idea like whatever but
I did I did [ __ ] him and then like
afterwards he gave me 300 bucks and I
was like what the hell I was so psyched
I was like the I was happier than I'd
ever been ever in my life I was like I
couldn't believe it I mean because you
know like I had like the other part but
I was like the money was like that was
amazing it was off the hook and when
you're like 16 and you have that much
money and you've never had that much
money it's you know
did you feel like you discovered a new
career well I feel like I'd not admit
career but I mean at that point I didn't
really think about careers but I knew I
had discovered something
and I um I kind of I guess you could say
ran with it because
I've ever okay ever since then I never
ever have done really anything else like
the day I turned 18 I went to the strip
club got a job and then I just
progressed like I started doing Bachelor
parties and then I started escorting
eventually I started doing porn I did
the track work like you know we were
outside working or in Vegas I've worked
in drinky parlor I mean drinky bars
massage parlors and that a lot of girls
don't get the opportunity necessarily
because it's an Asian thing with those
two things specifically
so there's a drinky bar
um okay like you've seen the karaoke
bars in the Koreatown and stuff sure
well they're basically just like [ __ ]
houses and a lot of people don't know
that
um so when you go in you know you
there's all these really pretty girls
and then they'll come and sit down and
have a drink with you and the drink
costs usually like something like 20
bucks right so the house gets a certain
amount and then the girl gets a certain
amount and then she just sits there and
drinks with you but they have these
karaoke rooms right private rooms so the
whole I you know thing is to get a guy
to get rent one of the rooms or whatever
and then whatever happens back there is
you know between the girl and the client
or whatever and um
you know obviously like they encourage
the more money that's coming into the
house is you know better and so
but I mean it's it's funny because some
people like for their prostitution needs
they have to they have to mask it
somehow you know what I mean like I I
honestly first whatever is well traveled
or as much as I know I did not know that
strip clubs were
like straight up whorehouses too like I
actually had thought for a long time
that they were kind of like um you know
the way certain trips are like oh I
don't do this I don't do that or like
you know I'm just a dancer like wrong
that's not
you're not going to last too long in
that environment if you're just a dancer
there's no way that's why there's back
rooms well okay snotting sometimes even
about the back rooms like Yeah well yeah
the champagne room that's pretty
um yeah it's pretty awesome but okay and
it really gets a good strip club or any
strip club if you don't start
interacting with some of their bigger or
like more regular clients or the clients
that are coming in and dropping like
five ten thousand at a time
if you don't interact with those clients
and by interact I mean they will want to
[ __ ] you period you know what I mean
like
then you're not gonna make it like you
know you're not going to get shifts or
like the managers that are working are
gonna like say no you can't work when
you come in or just you know what I mean
it's their
basically too it's it's just everything
is going to start to be more difficult
you know and and you're not gonna make
much money and so yeah it's just not
going to work out for you very well you
know
because some girls like they are under
the impression that they're going to be
dancing you know and uh no that's they
the champagne room is is what it's all
about in all strip clubs the house is
pushing that and if you don't
you know what I mean if you're only
making your money on stage then
that's you're not making much money
number one but number two like they
would give a rat's ass whether you're
there tomorrow or the next day or
whatever because you don't you know
what would have been your experience
what are the differences that you you've
seen between like doing porn and doing
uh escorting and stripping and
what do you do what are you doing
currently okay well
currently I'm pretty much a straight up
hoeing and that word is like offensive I
think or scary for some people but it
doesn't bother me I don't like see it is
a bad thing
um
but I don't really have to try to like
okay like if I go somewhere even if I'm
not dressed in a certain way or whatever
I mean like at night okay I go to the
liquor store I'll just be wearing jeans
like tennis shoes I'm not I sometimes
I'll have my dog with me and dudes will
start following me like I mean they will
aggressively start you know trying to
pick me up they did like they'll pull up
next to me or they'll try to like cut me
off like you know like before I hit a
street or something
and then they're just like hey what are
you doing or you know they'll like be
like how much or like hey do you smoke
you know and stuff like that do you need
a ride and um
it's it's kind of interesting because I
don't think every girl gets that you
know like when she's walking down the
street but
for some reason I put out that Vibe or
something is it because you're Asian
Asians no no no that's actually they
they
that's actually like they think I don't
or they're they're never assuming that I
maybe am a hoe because there's hardly
any Asians in the sex well okay that's
in the sex worker industry in the
American mainstream sex work industry
not that's very very few and far between
but in the human trafficking sort of
other side of it yeah almost every
Korean massage parlors got Korean chicks
in there like fresh off the boat don't
even speak English they're actually here
getting their visas or whatever and
um they stay housed they don't ever
leave they don't you know I mean they
don't have that same whatever you know
pimps they don't have all that they're
just like their pimps is the mama son
okay well there for instance the coldest
pimp I would ever say like you'll ever
meet is a mama son an old Korean woman
oh you think like there's no pimp I've
ever met that is as gnarly or basically
would put as much pressure on you or
whatever to do things as a older Korean
woman who's running massage parlor like
they are diehards like they
know that to get the money like I mean
they're just there's no Beyond it's like
the customer's always right times a
thousand like they they're so
accommodating that it's kind of
disturbing you know
it is it's been your experience between
like stripping porn and oh well
prostitution
okay I don't like the the well the money
the the take of it like basically like
how much you get or like how much is
taken and stuff
that that comes into play like the only
thing I don't like about strip clubs is
how much money the house is going to get
you know like we're talking like pretty
much almost 50 of everything you're
getting they're gonna get and that's oh
oh and then they do some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
okay look no girl gets a job stripping
so she can get a check or she can wait
till Monday of next week or whatever so
I worked at a good strip club here in LA
and they have Funny Money number one so
the guys buy this funny money so you
know so it comes up on their credit card
as like whatever it doesn't say like a
strip club and then they pay the girls
with the funny money but the thing is is
that you can't cash out all the funny
money at the end of the night and then
they'll tell you okay you can come on
Mondays but then sometimes on Mondays
they'll tell you oh we don't have that
much whatever and they'll they'll say oh
we'll give you a check
like are you kidding me like I haven't
had an ID in like six years like how am
I you know How's that gonna work like so
that [ __ ] is kind of like
that's it's kind of [ __ ] up and then
sometimes the girls end up selling their
funny money to other girls who who are
patient or maybe a little more stable
and so they're basically you know like
they're selling like 500 for like 300 in
cash which is crazy so so it's like
after all this is said and done like
let's say you made a thousand dollars
you're walking out of there with like
250 or something that that's that's
crazy right like I mean I think it's
crazy
but um and then you have to tip
everybody you have to tip the dorm and
you have to tip the bartender you have
to tip the house mother you have to take
the man are usually on shift so
I don't I that system is kind of like
whatever I don't like that whole
but as far as like um the atmosphere it
can be kind of fun it can be more fun
you know because like you're around a
lot of [ __ ] and and then it's
actually a lot safer I would say like
because you're in-house and you know
they're pretty on top of all that like
you know guys that are looking to hurt
women they're not going to go to strip
clubs to find those women so so that
that's cool and everything
um but it is like definitely more like
organized crime related there's a there
is a lot like organized crime
um people that tend to operate those
businesses
so there's you gotta kind of tread
lightly with some of them there's a lot
of like russian-owned or uh
um some a few of them Asian but like
basically there's Mafia money behind it
so you kind of have to be careful like
about certain things in the porn world
oh the porn world is um as I mean I okay
I have a tattoo on the back of my neck
that says born to porn and I didn't even
get that when I was doing porn I got
that actually when I was um on the track
in Waikiki Hawaii which is like a famous
track
but um
I got it because I I realized that I
knew what I was gonna I knew what I was
meant to do my whole life which was suck
dick for money or you know like other
stuff too but really I would say the
number one thing is the dick sucking
that's what most people are paying for
um
but like I just I just I came full
circle I was out on the track one night
and I was like you know what like I just
I wasn't even having a good night it
wasn't fun but I realized like that's
what I was meant to do in life you know
like that was my calling or whatever
so
I got the tattoo because
you know like I I was just like this is
what I was meant to do like this is what
God wanted he designed me for you know
in his life so
um but porn is pretty uh pretty [ __ ]
up industry it is there's some real
[ __ ] up [ __ ] going on especially with
like the testing and all that and the
stuff that has come up you know like
there's a couple stories in the media
but
just the
um yeah the testing aspect of it is
pretty crazy and then you it's another
thing where you have to um you have to
be accommodating to certain directors
because if you're not you're not going
to get work
so it's like you know if there's a
director and he wants to hang out with
you and he's gross and he's old and he's
fat or he's just an [ __ ] if you don't
want to hang out with him you might miss
out on a lot of work
and there's a major buddy like this
system is that the people tend to work
with all the same people like you know
Adam Sandler movies he got the same crop
of actors whenever it's a lot like that
in porn like the guys who like working
with each other they will work with each
other over and over and over and they
will basically refer people who they you
know have good experiences with and
sometimes even if the girl is not that
great on camera or she you know doesn't
look that great or whatever if she was
accommodating they're going to refer her
you know she's going to get more work so
it's just all about like honestly the
thing is I guess in all these industries
except I would say
track work which is like but then you
have your pimp to deal with usually like
but you have to be accommodating and
you're gonna have to [ __ ] some guys you
don't want to [ __ ] or like
uh but that's the nature of the Beast
you know and you think that'd be easy
for someone who's doing that work to
begin with but
sometimes it's not you know like it's
just
but I'm what they call Renegade a
renegade hoe which is like a hoe who
can't be pimped on basically and um
that's pretty accurate I would say like
I I have had a pit before but um
it just was coincidence like he was my
boyfriend he happened to be a Pim so you
know but I I I didn't seek that out kind
of thing do you feel like the the sexual
abuse in your childhood kind of set you
on this path well I'm kind of maybe in
denial or something or whatever about
that I'm not in denial I actually don't
think um
I think I personally think I'm sexually
one of the healthiest people I know
because I don't ever compromise myself
not anymore like never I I have sex for
me and I have sex when I want to have
sex with who I want to have sex and I do
not like like I said compromise myself
so basically if a guy makes me feel
uncomfortable or if I'm not in the mood
or if whatever then I'm not going to do
it whereas before when I was younger and
starting like I felt a lot of pressure
for different reasons but not anymore
and then also
like I don't have that okay I've had
some real bad things happen but I don't
have that many issues with the guys who
I'm seeing because
like if I get a bad Vibe I'm not gonna
go [ __ ] like whistle you know I'm not
gonna go to a room or go wherever with
some guy but most of the guys that
actually do this are really nice they're
respectful they're they're cool they
just you know they just want to [ __ ] a
woman who like doesn't hate getting
[ __ ] or like you know
I mean tell me about the scar on your
chest oh um well that's I got stabbed um
and my heart chest lung which is like
three major organs that was like in
2015.
it was pretty bad um I can I show you
the scars
this is so
it's like this
right here and this and this one are the
three actual entry points right but this
and all this
that's from them saving me okay so
and it so the guy I didn't know him I'd
never seen him before and
um
I thought he was trying to pick me up
for a date and he had like a a crystal
meth pipe and ten dollars in his hands
and so I started going off on him like
yelling at him talking [ __ ] to him like
being kind of uh rude and in your face
and then I told him to um like stay out
of the hood and to leave [ __ ] alone
you know and stop bothering them with
his kind of [ __ ] and I snatched the
ten dollars out of his hand
and um I just walked off whatever I went
to go get a soda at the place at this
restaurant right across the street and
then I walked back to where I was and um
when I was coming down the alley he was
waiting uh
he was waiting in the parking lot of an
apartment building and I couldn't see
him but he could see me so when I got
about 20 feet away he just came out
and he didn't say anything he was a very
calm very very calm collected he just
walked right towards me he looked me
right in the eye the whole time and then
he got close to me and I knew what was
going to happen like a second before
because I saw the hand go up but I never
saw the knife I actually didn't but I
saw the hand go up and I was like [ __ ]
and then he just went boom boom boom
just like that
heart chest lung and then he just walked
off
and he just that's it he was gone
like they're
like catching him oh yeah right that no
way in hell like that's gonna happen
unless maybe he got caught up for
something else but
you know that especially where it
happened the police aren't really caring
too much about stuff like that and um
because there were some other things
around that like just the area and
everything it
it wasn't I don't think it was a high
priority and there was hardly no
investigating done and you know so
but I know that guy has done this like
I'm 100 sure he has stabbed someone
before but I'm pretty sure he's killed
people like you don't wake up and just
do stuff like that nobody wakes up and
goes for like
kill shots like that you know what I
mean and just but is that comfortable
stabbing someone like that you know and
look at you in the eye while he doesn't
yeah and just calm like I said he was
very calm collected and the thing is he
was so nondescript like he was just
average height average looks he wasn't
ugly he wasn't all that handsome he was
the kind of guy who could like slip into
a crowd or slip out of a crowd
and
black or white or Mexican it's just kind
of like man it freaks me out because
like okay so at first I didn't think he
he was maybe living in my area because
I was on the streets I was running the
streets like crazy and and even if you
don't really know who the people are you
know who everyone is out in the streets
whether you know whether it's drugs hoes
whatever
gang bang and I've never seen this guy
before never and so
it was I don't know like
but I thought maybe he was from
somewhere else like South Central
Compton but then when I was like wait a
minute you know the way he laid and wait
to Ambush me how he knew where to wait
and then how quickly he got away I was
like he he has to be living in the area
you know to to know that and
so like I have a very good memory like
very good memory but
I if I saw him I wouldn't know it was
him I really wouldn't and and I know
that sounds crazy to people but
I wouldn't know who it was and like the
crazy thing was like there was probably
times where like maybe he saw me but uh
I didn't know that I was seeing him you
know like we could walk right by each
other on the street and I wouldn't have
known that that was the guy
so you think you're addicted to this
lifestyle
um for the fast money
well I think I'm addicted to yeah sort
of
um
I think I'm a sex addict actually first
and foremost I think because I'm one of
the few girls that
like actually I have to like tone it
down sometimes around certain girls I
know that our other girls are working
because
like I don't hate it as much as everyone
else you know like nobody's forcing me
these never forced me like I don't
really see like a lot of the clients
like oh they're old they're fat that
this or that you know like they're gross
or whatever like I don't have to get
high like super high before I do a date
or something like I think actually I
kind of like the um some of it you know
like I like the anonymity of it I guess
of having sex with different guys and
stuff
and the money is just like even better
but
but you've been in love before have I
been in love
um I thought so but now who knows you
know because after everything is said
and done sometimes you're like oh was I
really
your kids uh you sort of yes I mean I do
but
I've had three kids but I only have one
kid left so
meaning you lost them
um
uh I have one of my kids died and as a
result of a drive-by shooting in 2007.
sorry
yeah it sucked
um and then I had I got pregnant in 2008
not on purpose but I was not in any way
gonna be having that I I couldn't there
was no way I could do that you know and
I I was too late to have an abortion and
[ __ ] so I ended up getting the baby for
adoption actually but that was a good
thing it ended up being a good thing you
know there was no inhale I was gonna
have
another baby after everything that had
happened so in your third
oh no that was my third so it's like my
I have a well I have a daughter she's
24. oh really yeah
she's
she's awesome
you talk to her still oh yeah I do
it's like that's the only thing in this
world that I guess drives me or
motivates me to be a decent person or
like do the right thing because you know
I just don't want to make her any more
upset than I already have in life
so like that's the only reason I pretty
much behave myself is because I don't
want to make her upset
what emotions do you go through with
this lifestyle
um mostly I think I'm I
I think I suffer from depression overall
ever since I was little you know like
but
um
honestly I I don't know why that is
necessarily I mean yeah all the bad [ __ ]
that's happened but I'm pretty good at
um
like
like I don't know being self-aware and
kind of like dealing with [ __ ] like that
or like not being a little baby about it
you know or
so
I don't know like I guess I don't know I
feel like sometimes I just don't I never
have felt like I fit in quite anywhere
so I guess I've always felt like I was
completely alone no matter who was
around me or you know how many friends
or family I had
I didn't ever feel
any sense of belonging anywhere
I I actually accept in the [ __ ]
sex worker world and in the
world like my boyfriend is in and stuff
so what have you learned about men from
doing this oh
um I have learned that men are total
pervs pretty much um they are there's I
would say in no way no way are they
capable of monogamy no man is capable of
just having sex with like one woman in
on any level you know what I mean not
for life not for a week not for
um men are just highly physical
creatures highly physical and and also
but men are men are a little more like
relaxed and simple about like their
judgments or like they don't see the
same things that women see when you know
they look at other human beings
so
um like the things I think are gross
like no guy has ever been like oh that's
gross
so
I'm actually I like men I like men a lot
like um I used to be the kind of girl
who only had guy friends you know but
uh I don't put them on a pedestal I
don't think they're better than women or
anything but I do I like men like like I
like everything about them you know like
the way they operate sometimes they're
just just how they conduct themselves
you know
but I think they kind of have a little
better in this world because
you know they're gonna do whatever they
want and there's really nobody answered
it to or like to call them names but as
females it's totally different Do You
Believe In Love
um yes I do but
but I think it's just like a very
short-term thing I don't think it's yeah
I do believe in love but I think it's
just something that happens and then it
goes away it's like a firework you know
I mean
it's nice but it's like it will never
last never
never and so but [ __ ] like that'll
last like I've had clients
they were my clients for so long that I
was like
I mean they've got lasted any other
relationship in my any in any part of my
life like I got I've
like I don't have a single best friend
who I could say like oh for this many
years but I have clients where it's like
I've been yeah regulars that have lasted
[ __ ] often I mean like for like over
like almost 20 years you know
and that's it's crazy because like
okay so like if I'm not actively working
because my boyfriend is kind of like oh
he's got issues
he's Mexican so you know what I mean
they're not really cool with that but
like if I step out and like certain
clients see me they they there's no
whatever they're gonna you know they
will have to like talk to me whatever
try to get a date with me and um
it's pretty cool because like I don't
know that makes you feel at least like
not like desired but it makes you feel
like like you're actually um I don't
know like your work ethic is good you
know like you're providing a service
where it's like it's so
you know like good that basically a
person is gonna continue to come back
and like seek you out even though
there's plenty of other options for it
you know but they're you're a sort of
therapist oh almost oh yeah but I'm a
good hoe like I'm a really good hoe and
I've I've worked on that though because
I didn't always used to be when I first
started out what does a girl need to
know to be a good hoe well I don't think
there's anything okay the girls are the
best hoes are the girls who actually
like [ __ ] you know the girls who like
getting [ __ ] they're going to be the
best hoes period
because
you know I mean come on are you gonna
you're gonna be a good football player
if you don't like you know running or
catching balls I highly doubt that so
yeah if you like to get funked then but
really truly like to get [ __ ] and I
like to get [ __ ] because you want to
get a boyfriend or because that's what
you're supposed to do or because you're
going to get money or drugs out of it
like you like to get [ __ ] because you
like to get [ __ ] yeah that if you like
that then then that hoeing is probably a
really good thing to maybe check out or
look into and I think every woman is
actually hoe it's just that not
I mean but you tell some girls that oh
they will [ __ ] just have a fit
especially like some of my friends oh
they're they're all low-key hoes but if
you call them a prostitute they would
probably want to fight you you know so
you're saying a woman who's got a
husband and well yeah in a way she's
prostituting herself too I mean straight
up like but
okay like
yeah I mean actually I do I just think
women do it for different things and I
just do it for the straight up money
it's like I tell my girls all the time
I'm like look you're gonna say that
you're being more honest than the house
well all I gotta tell my girlfriend's
like look have you ever sucked dick
before I'm like because if you had you
would know that you should get money for
it so girls that want to look at me like
I look down them you're looking at me
like I'm bad because I
you know what I mean because I do joke
make a lot of jokes about dick sucking
money but it
like yeah if you ever select a dick you
should know that you should get paid for
it because it's
you know it's like it's kind of whatever
no girl wakes up and wants to just suck
dick it's either you do it for a reason
you know you you do it for what you're
gonna get out of it and that being said
I mean I prefer just cold Hard Cash you
know
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that do this kind
of work
um
well
oh that's a
I don't know about that but I okay I
would say that the the hardest thing to
deal with in this is
the lack of um respect for your life
that certain people have
like that that is probably and that
everyone else
um doesn't care about like
anytime a serial killer or just some
some really violent man or whatever
wants to
choose to do something really disgusting
and violent and bad the First Choice
almost always first choice is a working
girl
and
to to know that your life is totally not
has no value not only to these men but
to society the rest of society that's
like kind of a
that's like a lot to deal with you know
what I mean that's kind of hard
thing to accept or to to live with
and um to know that like
nobody would care if something really
[ __ ] bad happens to you or if you
just disappear or whatever just because
of what you do for
you know what I mean like for the money
or just just because you prostitute or
whatever like then it's okay for people
to kill you or you know like that that
is I have like a hard time with that
like that's something really [ __ ] up
and
I don't think people understand like um
like how how sick that is like from a
sociological like like a sociological or
psychological point of view because
we're all human beings like you know
we're supposed to care so much about
each other and value life but
I'd say a lot of people don't
what is what are the advantages of being
Asian
the benefits of being an Asian outworker
um
there's very few of you well okay you
are in high demand for the most part but
um there is that thing the whole thing
about
um American and
basically like Korean or whatever other
authenticity it's hard if you're
Americanized or westernized it's hard to
get a job or to work within the Asian
community of of sex work right and then
um it's also hard for the the fresh off
the boat ones to get involved on the
more um westernized side of it because
okay like at the this one massage
brother I was always getting picked um
when the guys had the choice I was
always getting picked and usually it
would be because I spoke English like
that's what the guys would end up like
basically would break down to so it was
about communicating being able to
communicate you know
um but then again then there's guys who
I totally like offend them like I'm like
oh they don't lie because I'm loud
because I talk too much or because I'm
not like that demure quiet you know not
a typical Asian well the stereotypical
like what they desire
um
and I would say yes most most guys that
like Asian women they're expecting you
to be extremely quiet
um very submissive
uh to giggle a lot I don't know to like
but just to be very accommodating to
them to not question them you know and
to just
yeah you're Cut From a Different Cloth I
I mean yeah but it's like I don't
understand how some of these guys can be
like think that you really are enjoying
being with them okay like I tell girls
if you can't make it fake it right but I
also tell them you should never do
anything if you don't like this kind of
work like don't do it because you'll
[ __ ] yourself up so bad and down the
road you'll be shot you'll be like you
won't be able to have a normal
relationship with a man to save your
life you know if if you allow yourself
to be compromised or do things you don't
really want to do
it will ruin you for you know and okay
then you add the drugs to it it's extra
bad
so
I don't know like it's can a girl who
does sex work well okay like you ever
become a housewife ah
um well yeah of course but I mean
I probably would be [ __ ] a bunch of
other guys on the side or something like
okay it's the point now where it's kind
of funny I a few years back I got to
this thing where I was like I was like I
used to watch like the Phil Donahue show
and [ __ ] when I was younger right like
she was like that and they'd always have
these hardcore black hoes on there and I
remember like like seeing them and
thinking like wow because some of these
women were so fat and ugly whatever but
they would be talking about like making
thousands of dollars and how like no guy
would even talk to them unless they were
breaking bread unless you know they were
hooking them up or giving them money and
I was like what the [ __ ] right like I'm
like looking at his room like no way as
I got older oh I I got I realized oh
yeah it doesn't matter what you look
like it matters about like where what
your intent is where your heart's at or
like how how you treat the guys you know
like your work ethic on that
because I have seen some of the fattest
ugliest girls make a lot of money and
have a lot of regular clientele because
girls were like super hot super young
super whatever I still plan on skinny
all that they think they're just gonna
go anywhere and they're gonna kill it
you know they're gonna be desired oh and
that's not necessarily true not at all
and and actually it takes a while to
build up like you could have some girl
and she's super hot super young blonde
skinny everything you put her on the
track
she's might not get it like the way you
think she would at first because there's
sort of a trust thing and there's a
comfortable like like that Comfort level
issue so
well with attractive it's different like
look at the prettier you are it's kind
of like
the more shady it gets for the guy
because he doesn't think it's like too
good to be true so they start
questioning what's going on and they
either think you're a cop or just
whatever you know I get a lot of that
actually I get a lot of that and I would
say this technically I'm too pretty to
be doing track work you know like
working the streets like actual like car
dates and all that but to be honest
that's
a round for round pound for pound if
you'd like whatever that is probably my
number one
um pick of all the sex work all them
because
I guess of the like the little details
that it involves you know you make
better money there well you okay yes and
no no no no no not really but but that's
because I'm a lazy hoe
um but you can I mean look a girl okay
because my last time I was escalating my
rate was 500 an hour like that's online
it's documented
but the thing is is that um with all the
the the online stuff is like everything
you do gets
um monitored and gets talked about on
these uh sites where they have review
boards and stuff right they I mean they
talk about everything how your breath
smell digital cigarettes blah blah blah
and how you look and everything is like
basically if they're paying 500 an hour
like now you're gonna you have to have
your nails done your hair done you know
you have to be looking like 500 an hour
but when you're working the track or
like basically just getting a date
wherever you know and uh it's so much
more easier it's like you can have a
cast on you could have barbecue sauce
stains on your shirt you'd have like
bruises all over your body you could
have a like [ __ ] up lip but you
you could have not showered in like five
days and you will still get a date you
know like somebody will still pick you
up which is awesome because you know
like
honestly the worse you look it just it
doesn't matter like
and sometimes I think it even helps you
like the more like [ __ ] up or sad or
like injured or something you might look
like that might actually help you get
more dates you know it's not necessarily
the most beautiful Wednesday Wednesday
well okay with the car with the with the
tracks I think there's actually the guys
are a little bit sicker I would say
they're well they're not sicker they're
just they're a little grittier like what
what it is they're looking for is um
a little more um
blue collar or something you know a
little more like um back of alley type
of thing because there's some guys that
like you know strip club guys are
totally different than escorting guys
than track guys and massage parlor guys
they actually all because yeah when you
said something earlier
and when I think about they are very
different very different guys they they
want different things and different
levels of behavior from you you have to
develop a very interesting skill set
because you know yeah like every guy's
gonna be different personality well
right in like some okay so some guys
they'll like hook you up with all kinds
of stuff and they really want you to be
like super appreciative they they want
to hear the thank yous and the you know
and then some guys don't want to even
hear it all like almost like that you
don't even want to be reminded of the
fact that they were so generous with you
or whatever
and
the worst thing I think a girl can do is
to ever ever become dependent or solely
reliant on
a trick or I don't really don't like
using that word but on a client or
whatever because oh you will get [ __ ]
so bad like
and the ones especially the more they
give you and then you just like it's so
it is it's so awesome it's hard to like
step back from but you should because oh
would he when he stops or pulls a rug
out from under your feet or decides for
whatever reason
that you [ __ ] up and he doesn't want
to do this anymore with you it's going
to be bad like you're gonna it's it's
gonna be real bad like it'll set you
back so hard it's not even funny
it it's horrible
because like the most
the guy that did the most for me ever
and like all my career of
hoeing oh man when he pulled back like
oh that was it was rough I mean it was
really rough I got really [ __ ] off
like actually for like a lot for a year
after that just because you know I
I was just being stupid and I had just
basically got so comfortable with you
know him hooking me up and whatever and
then I had kind of stopped
providing for myself I guess you could
say
Genevieve what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
um
I uh did not
to not judge a book by its cover
basically per se because
you you never know who it's going to be
that's gonna like gonna be like the big
because it really if it's all about the
money you know like the guys who spend
the most money or who basically put the
most money in your pocket tend to be
guys who you were not expecting that
from you know
and so I would just say yeah don't judge
a book by its color cover or like don't
be so quick to think that this guy you
know couldn't or could do this for you
because you'd be surprised at who you
know
just who the who the cool guys and the
guys who are like you know
actually like
don't hate women and you know they just
want to have a good time they're not
trying to hurt you they're not trying to
hurt their wives they're not trying to
you know make up for some ego thing they
just want to have a good time that's it
like
those guys like though that's your bread
and butter and so it's like but the ones
that really like make it possible to do
like really you know amazing things or
sometimes to even get out of business
for a year or two those you just you
know it's it's actually usually the guy
you're least expecting it from
all right Genevieve thank you so much
for sure you're welcome thank you for
having me thank you the best of luck out
there thanks thanks oh look like has
nothing to do with it